good morning this is inking live in our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well shell has
reported a better than expected profit
for the first three months of the year
despite lower oil and gas prices the oil
major reported adjusted earnings of 9.65
billion dollars for the period that was
down for a 9.8 billion dollars during
the final three months of 2022 but up
5.7 on the same period a year ago it was
also comfortably ahead of the 8 billion
dollars towards which it had been
guiding investors or shell said the
performance was driven by improved
operational performance and a strong
performance in energy trading well
joining me now is Nick Butler he's an
energy Economist and visiting professor
at King's College London Nick good to
see you this morning
um I mean there is a bit of a narrative
at play that uh oil comp and gas
companies earnings just go up and down
in line with the oil and gas price but
all of the majors thus far Exxon BP
shell they're all beating expectations
despite lower commodity prices
yes they are I think that we'll find it
difficult to see that sustained through
this year
uh the first quarter the prices were
beginning to come down they weren't down
as far as the as far as they are now so
I think after this very good quarter for
Shell in terms of finances uh we'll see
a much reduced uh level of Revenue
through the rest of this year unless Mr
Putin launches another attack on
European energy spies absolutely now I
mean both BP and shell have produced
better than expected earnings better
earnings than a year ago despite the
fact that oil and gas prices are lower
it all looks to be done to a solid
performance in their trading operations
yes that's that's what the numbers say
uh they seem to have sharpened their
their acts they're doing very well uh I
think it's a great day for shareholders
I'm a bit disappointed they haven't said
more about what they're doing on their
climate agenda that seems to have gone a
little quiet but it's undeniably a good
result for cell shareholders and people
who have shell shares in their pensions
and also of course they will pay more
tax because these are profit related
taxation systems in in this country and
they are going to pay quite a lot this
quarter Nick I'll come back to you on
the air climates issue in a moment but I
just want to home in on trading because
the all majors are all quite secretive
about just how much money they do make
from their trading operations why is
that
uh well I don't think uh you can't rely
on them that trading is how you handle
the market uh so they're not something
that can be predictably managed as you
can manage the supply of oil or gas or
uh their their roll out of uh electric
vehicle charging systems uh it's very
volatile therefore I think they don't
tend to report them all the time because
they go up and down they do seem to have
gone up in this quarter
yeah there's a very interesting piece of
analysis by uh the research firm
Bernstein quoted in the Ft today
suggesting that the likes of BP and
shell are actually making more from
Trading than the more focused trading
firms the likes of trafagira Vito and
gumfor I thought that was fascinating
yes well they they have they're very
skillful and they know the market
worldwide and that they are um some of
the best in the business uh I think some
of the smaller companies are obviously
in not quite so Global and not quite so
aware of how the market is going which
is what you really need if you're going
to trade at this level of activity and
to be very profitable
now this is the first quarter under
which uh well so I'm the new chief
executive has been in charge what have
you made of his performance to date
rather quiet actually uh I cannot read
into what they've published this morning
what their strategy is for the future
what the balance is between oil and gas
and low carbon activity I think they
need to do both they're a great firm I
think they can do both personally I
think they should split the business
because it's rather hard to do two very
different things and conglomerates don't
usually work but they haven't got to
that I'd love to hear a really clear
strategy statement from Shell now
that's a really interesting observation
I'm in the argument against doing that
is that it's earnings from the fossil
fuel activities that essentially support
investment in Renewables for the future
you think they could do both separately
I think they could run them separately
and pass a percentage of the profits
from the oil and gas into the low-carbon
business but one they haven't done that
yet I I I think they and the others will
do that over time and I think it's very
good both for the development of low
carbon activity and for shareholders
because Shell at the moment like BP is
just valued on the oil price as you said
at the beginning uh if they had a
separate business we'd see just how
valuable the low carbon activity is
which is at the moment is just hidden
Nick it's very interesting you say that
I mean one thing that well Sawan has
done of course is folded the Renewables
division into into Shell's Downstream
division why would he do that
I don't know I think you better ask him
I I thought it was an unnecessary
organizational change
I suspect the logic is that they think
that going to low carbon is all about
the demand side of the equation and what
consumers are doing so it is in that
sense Downstream but I think it I I
haven't heard a logical justification
for it yet
so I think he's been very quiet I hope
he is presumably now got his feet under
the table and that he'll come on your
show and answer these questions which I
can only guess at
all right Amen to that Nick good to talk
to you this morning thank you
pleasure
now hard on the heels of last night's
decision from the U.S federal reserve to
raise its Benchmark interest rate by a
quarter of one percent to a range of
five to five and a quarter percent comes
the latest decision from the European
Central Bank well since July last year
the ECB has raised its main policy rates
from minus half of one percent to three
percent as it seeks to get to grips with
inflation including consecutive Half
Point increases in December February and
March when another interest rate Rises
widely expected today but amid signs
that inflation in the Eurozone is
starting to ease there's speculation
that the ECB could slow the pace of its
rate increases well joining me now from
Frankfurt is CNBC correspondent Annette
wise back Annette welcome to you I mean
that is the big debate here most people
think the ECB will tighten again today
it's whether they go for a quarter or a
half Point rise
well the majority of analysts do expect
that it will only be 25-5 basis points
because what you've referenced early on
because we're seeing a slight uh easing
of inflationary pressure it's early
signs I have to say we've seen core
inflation now at 5.6 the first drop
since June of last year also food prices
are decelerating once again it's still
high but it is a first sign as I was
saying that inflation is coming down and
um also we've seen Peak inflation of
course it takes a while until monetary
policy has its effect on inflation rates
as well some economists do suggest it's
a year and so the ECB only embarked on
its rate hiking cycle back in June of
last year so they were quite late to
that Hiking Game and now in economists
do expect today 25 basis points and
probably another two 25 basis points uh
hikes in the future in June and then
July and then the Central Bank should
also be done but the terminal rate
probably sitting at 3.75 another lending
survey was showing also published from
the ECB this week that demand for loans
is going down tremendously in the Euro
area the biggest drop since the great
financial crisis in 2008 that also shows
that the bank lending channel is working
that because of higher interest rates
people don't take out loans anymore and
that will have a severe decelerating
effect on economic growth in the Euro
area but then also on inflation so
that's the main picture here for the ECB
today and of course shrinking the
balance sheet will be another topic for
the press conference but most likely we
are not getting any substantial news
from the ECB on that topic today
okay I know it's got to leave it there
appreciate you joining me today thank
you
some other business news stories for you
now and next this morning reported a
downturn in sales for the first three
months of its Financial year the fashion
retailer said it's full price sales
during the 13 weeks to last Saturday
were down point seven percent on the
same period a year ago that was actually
better than the two percent decline it
had been forecasting but next said it
was too early to change its overall
sales expectations for either the half
or full year because May June and July
sales last year were flattered by
unusually warm weather and pent up
demand for events such as weddings and
proms
virgin money has reported a drop in
half-year profits after increasing the
Summit sets aside to cover loans it does
not now expect to be repaid in full
during the six months to the end of
March the lender set aside some 144
million pounds that was up from 21
million pounds in the same period a year
ago well that meant headline pre-tax
profits fell by 25 to 236 million pounds
the bank said the increased level of
impairments reflected to return to more
normal conditions following an unusually
low level a year ago
train line has returned to profit
following a recovery in the use of the
railways the rail ticketing app reported
a pre-tax profit of 22 million pounds
for the year to the end of February that
compared with the pre-tax loss of 15 and
a half million pounds during the
previous 12 months well Jody Ford the
chief executive said the train line had
sold around 200 million train tickets
across Europe during the period with
growth being driven by market
liberalization measures in countries
such as Spain
and the UK's competition regulator has
launched an initial review of the
artificial intelligence Market including
the models Behind Popular chatbots such
as chap GPT the competition of markets
authorities said the review would look
at how competitive markets for
foundation models and their use could
evolve and look into what opportunities
and risks they would bring for
competition and consumer protection the
CMA also expects to come up with guiding
sub principles to support competition
and protect consumers as AI Foundation
models develop
mothercare said this morning it had
begun talks with its lender to change
renegotiate or refinance its debt
facility The Specialist retailer for
parents and young children said this was
due to higher interest rates and added
it is also considering various financing
Alternatives including a possible sale
of new shares in the meantime it set a
delay to return to pre-covet 19 sales
levels particularly in Middle Eastern
markets meant it could need waivers to
conditions to be reset with its lenders
down now by more than 20 as you can see
on the on that news
[Music]
well Wall Street sold off last night
after the Federal Reserve took U.S
interest rates to their highest level
for 16 years with a number of mid-sized
lenders tumbling amid concerns over the
health of the banking sector pacwest
Bank Corp fell by 52 and Western
Alliance by 23 percent Pat West
indicating it's in talks with partners
and potential investors over its
strategic options
well stocks in the asia-pacific region
had a largely positive session overnight
despite that news out of Wall Street
Hong Kong and Shanghai were both ahead
on gains for financial stocks you can
ignore the figure for Tokyo in the top
left-hand corner of the screen that was
shut for a second consecutive day due to
public holiday well in Europe stocks are
largely in negative territory ahead of
this lunchtime's decision from the
interest on interest rates from the
European Central Bank talking points
this morning include the Danish drugs
giant Novo Nordisk a company we've
talked about a lot on this program of
late the shares are off some five
percent in Copenhagen that is on news
that it's reducing the supply of some
dose traits of its obesity treatment
regavi in the United States well here in
London the ftse 100 is also in negative
territory right now currently offered
just over half of one percent in a
broad-based decline that formed 43
points off right now would have been
worse were it not for Shell that's added
some 13 points to the index on its own
in terms of the major talking points
this morning where Hargreaves Lansdowne
is the leading Blue Chip Gainer
currently uh nearly three and a half
percent to the good that's on a trading
update and the Gold Miner Endeavor
mining that's ahead by some two and a
half percent for similar reasons on the
downside well there are a lot of stocks
going ex-dividend today in other words
they're trading for the first time
without rights to the latest payout so
the leading fallers there glencore his
Cox the insurance company and St James's
place so if you own shares in those
particular companies don't worry that's
just because they've gone X div today
outside the ftse 100 or Domino's Pizza
is ahead some one and three quarter
percent right now well yeah three
quarters right now that's on a trading
update lion trust Asset Management
really interesting company this we've
had the CEO on the program in the past
uh shares price off some five percent
right now that's on news that it's
paying 96 million pounds for the Swiss
fund manager gam never a quiet moment at
lion trust fascinating company that on
the foreign exchange markets ahead of
the European Central Bank decision it's
all pretty quiet Sterling more or less
unchanged against US dollar very
slightly ahead against the Euro I mean
while The single currency off uh nearly
a sixth of one percent right now against
the Greenback as for the oil price well
that has actually perked up this morning
on hopes that the U.S rate tightening
cycle isn't an end a barrel of Brent
crude is currently changing hands at 73
dollars 22 cents a barrel that is up one
and a quarter percent would you want to
be now live from Hong Kong it's the
investment director at Fidelity
International Catherine young Catherine
good to see you this morning uh what was
the uh impact of the fed's decision on
Asian markets I mean I commented there
that uh Financial stocks in Hong Kong
and Shanghai both doing well today
yeah so a lot of the news flow regarding
the FED has was already priced in so no
Major Impact and in fact people are
still looking at the data flow primarily
from China to ascertain whether there's
economic recovery is still on track so
interestingly we've just released or
we've just seen the release of the Labor
Day holiday data especially relating to
the consumption theme because
consumption is so key for economic
growth and some numbers looking actually
quite interesting there
what uh you've been uh Lighting on
though Catherine is the fact that uh
there seems to be a bit of a disconnect
between markets and some of the Chinese
data right now
yes it seems very odd because the
economic data is going in the right
direction somewhat surprising on the
upside yet sentiments as well as market
performance is very very sluggish so you
get the sense that people are somewhat
Treading Water some of this could be
related to geopolitical concerns some of
it could be related to again this
ongoing need to see visibility about
whether this economic recovery is indeed
sustainable so it does feel a bit weird
at the moment they're a bit strange
given that the economic data is so
positive
now Catherine I mentioned Japan
obviously it's closed for Golden week
just now but I mean the Japanese stock
market has been on a real tear recently
what have you made of that
yes I think because it's just sort of
been in the wings so as to speak and the
data again is looking very attractive
we've been finding a lot of very
attractive opportunities in the smaller
cap Tech space so sort of these
Innovative companies which look awfully
similar to what the Chinese Innovative
companies look like and you know you've
seen a change in terms of corporate
governance rules in in Japan so they're
really rewarding minority shareholders
something we've been anticipating for
quite some time so Japan really is
likely to continue to do well
and elsewhere in the region the other
big talking point this week I guess was
that surprise interest rate rise from
The Reserve Bank of Australia really
caught people uh on the Hop
it did and you know I was just actually
in Australia for a personal holiday and
uh you can see that the inflationary
pressures are definitely there and real
so the RBA or the result Bank really
trying to keep up with tanning or
reigning in inflation and again from a
regional perspective from a Global
Perspective the only Regulators or
policy makers which are at the other end
of the spectrum are the the Chinese so
the People's Bank of China and maybe
again this is why you're seeing this
Treading Water phenomenon because the
pboc isn't throwing everything in terms
of easing in fact they're being very
pragmatic and very targeted with their
policy all right Catherine we have to
leave it there I'm afraid I hope you had
a nice trip to us it's good to see you
again
thanks Ian take care
no barely a day goes by without a fresh
Revelation about someone having their
data or website compromised by hackers
yesterday for example brought news at a
Russian spy network has acquired
sensitive technology from EU companies
with the aim of supporting Vladimir
Putin's war in Ukraine well that has
served to underline the changing nature
of the threat with mobile gaming
currently seen as the latest breeding
ground for hackers well joining me now
from Vienna is Gustav Salman he's chief
executive of the Norwegian cyber
security firm promont Gustav welcome to
you why has gaming become the latest
Target for hackers I think it's a it's a
breeding ground where we can try a lot
of new attack vectors you can try a lot
of um malware and see if that works and
and of course you have a very big
distribution of these games on a mobile
basis on a global basis so of course you
know we're seeing and also it's a
generational thing that you have a lot
of people being acquainted with these
games and being quite Savvy at trying to
attack them and then they learn these
things and then they can apply those
techniques for for attacking other other
parts of the infrastructure which are
more more sensitive even than the games
itself so that's very interesting I mean
they're not necessarily just trying to
steal data they're using this almost as
a learning exercise you're implying
exactly you know we we're seeing I mean
now now we're seeing the Advent of the
world where of course you have things
like you know in the AI space you you're
being weaponizing the the bad guys in a
way that that wasn't um you know wasn't
around before and and you're seeing a
Much More Much richer set of attacks
against different types of of the app
ecosystem uh so which which is the part
where we're playing and securing the the
apps
one of the areas that you were quick to
a light on a few years ago was connected
cars is is that still as big a threat as
it once was of course I mean we live in
in a network Society everything is
connected to the internet and everything
is is you know we protect any app
anywhere you know and and of course the
car is it's it's good if the the car
does what you're you think it should be
doing uh rather than the opposite so so
so I think you know we the the core the
core industry everything which is this
is It's the world we're living in
everything is connected everything is is
is is is attackable and and that's just
to deal with because that's part of how
we live our lives today and and we have
to make sure that security Comes First
Security is really transformational if
you want to do it as a company if you
want to do a MOBA strategy you have to
make sure that you have your security in
place beforehand because otherwise you
know you're going to be running uh you
know it's a train crash waiting to
happen
okay Gustav I'm so sorry we're gonna
have to end the interview there because
we're a bit of breaking news to uh bring
the viewers do appreciate you joining me
today thank you thank you
yes we're gonna go across now to the
Hague the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zelenski is speaking we're going to
listen in
and do not tolerate tyranny as much as
we do not in Ukraine thank you very much
dear Minister hookestrom a dear members
of parliament dear ambassadors and
journalists dear representatives of
international organizations political
and judicial communities dear people
first of all people people
of the Netherlands and I'm glad to be in
your strong country now
now the land of freedom and Justice
which are Universal values and it is
about these things that I will speak
today of course of course we all want to
see different
Vladimir
here
in The Hague
the one who deserves to be
sentenced for these criminal actions
right here in the capital of the
international law
and I'm sure we will see that happen
when we win
and we will win
and when we win not just on the
battlefield not just against this
aggression look at how countries around
the world are coming together to help
ukrainians defend themselves
what is at the heart of this desire to
help
the feeling that more than the faith of
one country is at stake
the feeling that more can be achieved
than the defeat of one aggressor
we can now stop Wars of aggression as
such we can defeat aggression as a
criminal idea that
originates in the mindset of someone who
is used to impunity
immunity is the key that opens the door
to aggression
if you look at any War any any war of
aggression in the history they all have
one thing in common
the perpetrators of the world didn't
believe they would have to stand to
answer for what they did
they must tend to answer for war
however brings war must receive judgment
ladies and gentlemen
defeating impunity of aggressors means
destroying their origins of aggression
victory in the war is won by Force of
Arms
that's how how their job gets done
and I'm grateful to you to you and the
Netherlands for every piece of weapon
supplied to Ukraine for everything that
helps us to maintain our defense and
gradually prepare our active actions
but we know that the lasting peace after
Victory is achieved by nothing else but
the strengths of values first of all
it's the strengths of freedom
end of law
which must work to the full of Ensure
Justice
not hybrid promises
instead of Human Rights
real freedom
not hybrid impunity and symbolic
formalities but full scale Justice not
hybrid peace and constant flashes of
violence on the front line but reliable
peace when one respects values true
Freedom True Justice through peace is
respected instead of hybrid forms but
it's exactly what we need now
please think about one number
and now
um this number is 6139
this is the number
contradict number of war crimes
committed by the Russian occupies this
April alone
these Russian crimes led to the death of
207 Ukrainian civilians among them are
11 children and Adam another 17 children
are four and four hundred Terrors were
injured in a month's alone
and the full-scale Russian invasion has
been going on for the 15th month
just yesterday
yeah it was yesterday in our Houston
region alone Russia killed 23 people
49 were wounded
I'm speaking about civilians
and it all started more than nine years
ago with the occupation of
our land with the occupation of Crimea
and Russia's bloody hybrid war in the
donbas
thousands and thousands of war crimes
thousands and thousands of
victims the Russian rockets that killed
23 people in the city of uman and each
of the millions millions of strikes
fired by Russian Artillery in the donbas
every person killed by the occupiers in
Buchan and every filtration camp that
Russia set up on our independent land
every prisoners who was tortured in the
Russian captivity and every city
deliberately burned by Russia and all
the pain suffered by the by the Dutch
people after the dawning of
mh17
flight with the use of the Russian
weapons by the Russian hands exactly by
the Russian hands and please observe
a minute of silence in a memory of all
the those whose lives were taken by
Russia
by Easter
place
okay
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
France
um only only one Russian crime led to
all of these crimes
this is a crime of aggression the start
of evil
the primary crime
there should be a responsibility for
this crime and it can only be enforced
by the Tribunal
Europe and the world have already had to
deal with something like this as a
result we can see the falling wars in
the text
of the Judgment of the international
tribunal in Nuremberg
to initiate a war
a war of aggression is not only an
international crime it is the Supreme
International crime differing only from
other other war crimes in that it
contains within itself the
accumulated evil of the whole
that's absolutely true
we must transform the experience of the
Nuremberg process into operating role
that's why we insist on the tribunal
creation
when there is a tradition of inevitable
punishment of aggression then there will
be a tradition of guaranteed
non-repetition of aggression
if we want True Justice we should not
look for excuses
and should not refer to the shortcomings
of the current international law
but make make bold decisions that we
that will correct the shortcomings of
those Norms that unfortunately exist in
international law
this is exactly what their creators of
Nuremberg did we should do the same now
it would be a weakness for you and for
us and for all of the Nations to live
through Justice only to history it would
be unfair to our children and our
grandchildren to hand them problem that
we can solve that's what the tribunal is
for
then
their sustainability of peace arises
from the complete Justice towards the
aggressor
ladies and gentlemen
it is wrong that someone in the world is
still afraid to give full force to
Justice
you and I are not afraid and I am sure
most of the World is Not Afraid
the aggressor must feel the full power
of Justice only him yet this is our
historical responsibility of the modern
generation to make the total punishment
for aggression inevitable to prevent the
aggression against our country and also
new Wars there are potential aggressors
in the world and the world must see
Justice to see peace fully fully secured
Ukrainian courts will
ensure responsibility for most for most
of the crimes of the Russian occupiers
and I'm I'm very thankful to the
international criminal court and to the
entire team working at and with the ICC
for the sake of justice but only one
institution is capable of responding
to the original crime the crime of
aggression
a Tribunal
tribunal not
something hybrid
that can formally close the topic not
some compromise that will allow
politicians to say that the case is
allegedly done
but a true
winning true
full-fledged tribunal true and full
Justice
and I am thankful to you the people
leaders of the Netherlands prime
minister the government the parliament
for being with us on this path is so
important for us and I thank you for
supporting the establishment of the
special tribunal and I am grateful that
the international center for the
persecution of the crime of aggression
will work right here in The Hague
and same here in The Hague the register
of damages from aggression will be
established and this is a step forward
creating a compensation mechanism
damages from aggression must be
compensated at the expense of the
essence of the aggressor himself and
this is also a punishment for War as
well as Justice
I thank you for the fact that for you
and us Justice really matters
thank you
the Netherlands let's let Justice really
work and and when today as always as
always on the 4th of May at eight
o'clock in the evening you will on our
honor the memory of all those who whose
lives were taken away by by the by the
wars but then
second world war another War's place
also
remember ukrainians men and women adults
and children
who would have been alive now but
but for this aggression the war we
didn't want
the one we have to make the last and
we'll do it slow grain
[Applause]
president zielinski of Ukraine there
speaking in The Hague among the things
that he said there is that uh he wants a
war crime crimes tribunal to be set up
and he wants Vladimir Putin to be
brought before it to uh face punishment
from the International Community we'll
get a reaction to that speech throughout
the morning here on Sky News as we get
it
[Applause]
oh so we've been reporting on this
program regularly Global tourism has
rebounded sharply since the easing of
covered restrictions around the world
but that recovery has also highlighted
issues with which the industry was
grappling before the pandemic chiefly
carbon emissions eight percent of which
globally are produced by the travel
industry well addressing that is the aim
of the sustainable tourism Global Center
a multinational body set up under the
leadership of Saudi Arabia at the cop 26
Summit in Glasgow two years ago well
joining me now to talk about this is
Gloria Guevara she's the former
president of the World Travel and
tourism Council and now special Chief
Special advisor to the Saudi Ministry of
Tourism Gloria good to see you this
morning
um what was this uh body specifically
you're hoping to achieve thank you for
having me well basically we have
multiple challenges in the sector and as
you mentioned eight percent of the
greenhouse submissions are driven by
travel and tourism
eighty percent of the sector are smes
and these small guys they don't have the
solutions neither the resources to move
to climate neutral
for instance on a small restaurant how
do they know their footprint let alone
where they get the resources to move to
climate neutral and this Center aims to
be the One-Stop shop
where they can find all the solutions
and they can help us to accelerate the
transition what's success going to look
like here are you do you have key
performance indicators we do we do to
reduce food waste to move to renewable
energy but most important to help the
little guys what progress is tourism
made in reducing its emissions footprint
over the last decade that is a great
question because we have been having
some challenges in the past to track
because of the fragmentation of the
sector the big guys are doing a great
job
but we have been working in silos and to
tell you the truth we didn't have clear
measurements and this is one of the
things that the center is going to be
helping to measure exactly that yes you
have done some work on this already
which countries have made the most
progress I think Portugal was one that
you singled out for Price a lot of
countries are doing a good job but the
challenge is that the destination level
because it's very hard to measure as a
country level destinations are not
planning for their Travelers let me give
you one example
London 2019 receive 9 million citizens
21 million Travelers do you think that
we plan it for that
waste the water the energy similar
situation in countries like Spain 47
million visitors 47 million citizens 81
million visitors
you plan for the impact of the trash the
water and all of that so that is a big
Challenge and that's why this Center is
so relevant to health destinations smes
and of course Travelers you mentioned
that a lot of the issues around smes in
particular I mean presumably a lot of
these businesses are just looking to
recoup their covid losses as their main
priority absolutely these guys are
trying to survive
because of kovid a lot of the businesses
close they need to reduce their expenses
they don't have the money to invest to
move to climate neutral and they don't
even know how to start many of them if
you look back 10 years 15 years who's
helping the smes and this is one of the
reasons this Center is so important
because we're going to be helping the
little guys not only with the knowledge
the training
and to explain them how to reduce cost
their bill for energy the food waste for
instance the plastic usage
and help us to move to net serum they
need all the help from training
knowledge and funding of course now as I
mentioned in the introduction this body
was set up under Saudi leadership what
sort of buy-in have you had from the
rest of the world well this is a
multi-country multi-stakeholder
coalition and Saudi has invited a couple
of countries we're working very closely
with the U.S government with the UK
France Germany but also countries such
as Kenya Jamaica
Germany and others we're very Advanced
with the UK they care about the smes
they care about of course travel and
tourism and also with the U.S government
all right cool it's good to see you
again um thanks for being with us while
we've been to the live event thank you
thank you
and one consequence of the rapid rise in
interest rates during the last 15 months
has been a short slow down in Venture
Capital funding total VC investment in
the UK last year came in at 24 billion
pounds which was down 30 on 2021 or
among those grappling with the changed
environment is forward Partners which
specializes in backing early stage tech
companies and particularly in the AI
space today it announced a decline in
the value of its portfolio from 117
million pounds at the end of 2021 to 80
million pounds as at the end of 2022
will joining me now it's Nick Brisbane
he's the chief executive of forward
Partners Nick good to see you this
morning
um I guess another way of looking this
at this is to say that 2021 was really a
very very exceptional year
gosh 2021 was exceptional that's for
sure yeah
yeah boom Time Adventure capital
but uh what are you hearing now from uh
from from the the market more broadly
when do you expect funding conditions to
to improve more broadly
so that's that's the question on on
everybody's lips uh and what we've seen
so far this year is tentative signs of
confidence returning
um you know it's and the things we look
at uh investor interest in our portfolio
companies and then we're out talking to
other VCS all the time and you know
confidence was slow building through
January and February went sideways a bit
um through March after Silicon Valley
bank collabs then we're starting to pick
up and then we have some some more news
over the last seven days or so so things
are slowly improving but it's it's still
a bit fragile it's how I would summarize
like a lot of VCS are demanding a faster
route to profitability from their
portfolio companies is is that something
on your mind
yes so to say the same thing slightly
differently I think what's becoming
important is to be more Capital
efficient and to be able to get to
profitability and and exit and value
with less capital
but presumably uh you are still uh
finding opportunities that you're Keen
to invest in
oh for sure yeah I mean you can see
there's no annual report but we saw at 4
600 deals last year
um got serious with 70 invested in three
and deal for over remains very strong
there's a lot of great entrepreneurial
activity here in the UK and the big
thing here like the Tailwinds for for
technology for early stage Venture
Capital are really strong and that
doesn't change even when we have a
recession
there's obviously been an explosion of
interest in AI following uh the launch
of chat GPT are you getting a lot of
inbound inquiries on that
yes for sure I think these Technologies
are you know this large language models
or the Technologies Which underpin
chapter chats GPT they are very powerful
there's a lot a lot of productivity
games to be had from from them which I
think you know could drive economic
growth uh for for years to come and so
you know a very large percentage of the
new deals that we are getting serious
with are employing these Technologies
and a number of our portfolio companies
are also exploiting women think it's
very exciting for the future are there
going to be enough AI related
opportunities to invest in right now or
is there too much money chasing too few
opportunities
no there will be enough opportunities
I'm sure you know we're definitely not
at a point where we have too much money
in the market right now
okay Nick uh we lost a bit of time
earlier on during the program so we'll
have to call the halt on things a busy
day for your results today do appreciate
you spending the time to speak to me
thank you
now if you make an app to be sold on the
App Stores operated by Apple and Google
those companies will take a big chunk of
your earnings the power they enjoy to do
so is unregulated and is deeply resented
by developers well that may change in
the UK If the digital markets
competition and consumers Bill currently
going through Parliament makes it onto
the statute book that bill would confer
on the competition and markets Authority
the power to speed up Market
investigations into the tech sector
update consumer law and ensure the
enforcement of competition rules well
joining me now is Kelly Fair brother
she's chief executive and co-founder of
the UK based audio book zigzag Kelly
good to see you this morning is it over
egging things to say that Apple and
Google are running app store monopolies
no I think that's a pretty fair
description yeah they're using their
dominant positions in mobile operating
systems to insert themselves in my
transactions with my customers both uh
in you know forcing me to use their
in-app distribution or their in-app
payments and and their only apps store
which is the only one they allow on
their on their apps so how much do these
app stores clip from your earnings uh
well on every transaction they take
anywhere between 15 to 30 depending upon
how big you are as a company and just to
put that in perspective versus the you
know just a traditional online payment
service where you'd pay anywhere between
one and four percent yeah I mean for a
start a young startup I mean that's
potentially the difference between
profit and losses exactly yeah and you
heard just your guests before on you
know the power of
um the scrutiny that investors are
taking in in terms of unit economics and
and gross margins and so yeah that can
also impact your ability to access
funding and apart from uh taking away a
chunk of your earnings do they impinge
on you in other ways I mean do they
inhibit the way that you you can run the
business uh well I think you know it
forces you to make some decisions uh
like how do you want to serve your
customers it could cause you to want to
raise your prices in order to fund you
know in-app payments it causes a lot of
companies to to you know siphon
customers off onto a web-based
experience to then enjoy or redeem in
the app which customers don't understand
and it's just not a great experience for
them I mean I should actually say to to
viewers you're actually being quite
Brave in sticking your head above the
parapet a lot of tech companies are
pretty reticent to talk about this yeah
I think I think that's fair we're part
of the the Coalition for app fairness
which is a Consortium of of about 70
companies who all are in a position a
similar position to us and want to see a
free and fair operating of of uh of the
mobile app ecosystem and a lot of people
are scared that you know these Apple and
Google exert a great deal of power and
authority in terms of where you show up
in the rankings whether your app gets
approved and whether you're even on the
App Store and if they revoke that you
know that's half your Revenue gone
overnight so it's it's quite high risk
high stakes absolutely so are you fairly
optimistic about this bill going through
Parliament uh I'd say it's a it's an
important first step and
but we along with
along with rap fairness fairness are
working hard with uh the policy makers
and Regulators to ensure that this is
just a first step that the digital
markets unit has the authority it needs
to protect consumers and enable
competition in this space and allow more
choice for us particularly in the in-app
payments and app distribution generally
and how does the UK shape up with other
jurisdictions in terms of How It's
addressing this issue well I think all
all you know what's great is that it
it's you know on the agenda of a lot of
the different of different companies
both the EU and the US
and it's I think the governments are
trying to figure out how they can
actually get involved you've seen
different activities happening in the
Netherlands and South Korea and then you
know you're also seeing the backlash
um from from some of the Tech players so
it does feel like they're not going to
do it voluntarily so it's a really
important that the governments are
taking a stance to try to enable a fair
playing field but with regard to the UK
you must have taken some comfort from
the fact that the competition of markets
Authority has just blocked Microsoft's
takeover of Activision I mean that shows
that they are not afraid to take on the
really big guns of the tech world yeah I
think that was a surprising development
I would say
um and you know I'm not really in that
space so I can't I can't really comment
on the detail but yes as a theme of you
know willingness to stand up to Big Tech
uh yeah we welcome that I'd say all
right I'm afraid of a bit push for time
this morning Kelly but it's great to see
you thank you cheers
[Music]
time now for a lookout this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with comments
from the head of the London Stock
Exchange in which she said this was on a
Blog on the lse website yesterday that
UK Executives should be paid more if the
country wants to retain talent and defer
company deter companies from moving
overseas Julia hoggets said that we
should be encouraging and supporting UK
companies to compete for talents on a
global basis so that we remain an
attractive place for companies to base
themselves stay and grow where her
comments came on the day that the
financial conduct Authority suggested
rule changes to make the UK a more
attractive place to list on the stock
market well inside the financial times
it's columnist Helen Thomas says that
despite concerns that the rule changes
might make the market riskier the FCA is
right
well the times also carries Julia
hoggett's comments on its business front
page but it leads with last night's
interest rate rise from the U.S federal
reserve Julia hoggett also leads the
Daily telegraphs Business pages but it
also carries comments from Nigel Higgins
he's the chairman of Barclays in which
he said the world could not function at
present without fossil fuels he was
speaking as the bank's annual meeting
yesterday was disrupted by climate
change campaigners
and a reminder to check out the inking
live podcast which you can find by
scanning the QR code on your screen now
it's available now wherever you get your
podcasts including the Sky News app
Apple and Google podcast and Spotify
now the king's coronation is set to
deliver a huge boost to consumer
spending getting on for half the
population is expected to watch the
event on television hopefully on Sky
News attend a street party or social
Gathering or even travel to the event
it's estimated that at least one and
three-quarter billion pounds will be
spent mainly on food and drink but also
on decorations and memorabilia and
souvenirs will joining me now to talk
about this is Gabrielle de montessor
he's president of world pay Gabriel
welcome to you is it possible to say how
much it's going to be spent
um I would say no but we have some
presidents so if you look at the Jubilee
last year we clearly seen a massive
increase in consumer spent especially in
certain verticals so food and drinks
grew by 12 groceries grew by four
percent
um bear in mind though that last year
weather was good and we had one more day
to celebrate yeah so it's going to be
interesting to see how it goes to this
year yeah we're expecting a bit of rain
on Saturday aren't we indeed yeah and
the weather forecast is always a big
impact on consumer spend whether people
you know go outside or remain at home
you mentioned uh the uh the the sort of
precedent of the Platinum Jubilee last
year what about Royal weddings going
further back do they deliver a boost
yeah same so um each and every time
obviously a festivities people want to
go out so groceries hospitalities
restaurants you know get quite a big
benefit of that
um and obviously you must you've
mentioned it you know people want to buy
souvenirs and decorations and so forth
so the world industry I would say is
benefiting from that bear in mind also
that outside of the UK people are very
interested by this event so you've got a
lot of Tourism that's going to benefit
the UK are you already seeing uh
evidence of that of uh changes in
spending patterns no so we've seen in q1
so the first quarter already which says
some of the attractions on those
specific verticals reality is that we
don't have the statistics of the month
of April yet and bear in mind that last
year you know during the first quarter
we were still on the lapping of omnicron
and the kovid so this year we see a
massive boost in consumer spend 40 in
travel 30 in Hospitality 12 in groceries
you know and food and drinks but this is
mainly due to First inflation and second
the lapping of the cavil absolutely what
I mean you mentioned travel and tourism
there I mean there's a big debate raging
in this country about uh that free
shopping for Forum visitors tourism
Industries very you're upset about it I
mean how much is being spent right now
in the UK by International visitors I
don't have the statistic to be honest
um what we can say is obviously for the
past three years it's been very down we
see an increase on average ticket value
in the tourism industry by 10 and then
you have another 10 of I would say
inflation so roughing volumes are on
value it's an increase of 20 and on top
of that again you know because last year
was a very lawyer or the previous just
because of the curvied the overall
tourism industry is growing very very
fast meaning 30 40 50 depending on the
verticals where are these visitors
coming from by and large I mean the
Americans appear to be back in Europe
with a Vengeance yeah so uh Europeans
are one of the main I would say end
consumer corridors when it comes to uh
um tourism the US also is a a big one
and we also see uh since the beginning
of this year which was not the case last
year
um a big increase in travel careers with
Asia Pacific Asia Pacific was the last
region to open up after the pandemic and
so we see now the benefits in terms of
Tourism corridors which was not the case
last year yeah so more broadly than uh
you is this Chinese visitors essentially
so so was Pacific visitors uh in in with
on the fourth quarter last year and uh
the first quarter of this year is indeed
you know way more a Chinese Japanese and
Indians all right I mean there have been
various visa restrictions on some of
those groups in the past is that uh
creating a bit of friction these days
um I wouldn't be able to go into
specifics there uh with that said I've
got some statistics on the UK bi which
is you know the government websites to
get visas and I can tell you that it's
growing fast too Again difficult to
compare apples with apples because of
the overall pandemic but we see a big
increase there too now of course another
real interesting difference between the
coronation and past Royal events is uh
the internet I mean online obviously
cancel greater proportion of consumer
spending these days how does that affect
things so
um it does affects in term of I would
say end user consumption and usage so
one of the biggest I would say you know
benefits of for the providers you know
this weekend is going to be click and
collect you know providers delivery apps
you know all those kind of things we
still need to to bear in mind though
that Ecom e-commerce is only 20 of the
total I would say spend markets okay so
uh Point of Sales still represent 80
percent of the total value spend you
know in the UK so there is still a long
way to go for e-commerce websites to
take on uh the overall economy but uh
it's it's a big Trend the consequence of
that is a massive displacement of cash
so before the pandemic cash was still 21
of the UK markets after the pandemic
it's 10 and we forecast only six percent
in three years from now six percent Yeah
so basically we've displaced in five
years time we would have displaced a bit
less than 200 billion of you know
transactions of value into the digital
economy that's I mean that's almost on a
par with some of the Scandinavian
Nations yeah indeed which is which is
you know fairly interesting because for
the past 10 years we've always said that
the not next countries were you know
almost cashless with six foot percent of
cash in the economy but actually the UK
is you know starting to catch up
basically is and one of the biggest I
would say cashless Academy going forward
absolutely now before I let you go I
mean going back to the coronation we
should forget I mean it's very hard to
come up with a parallel in 1953 but in
those days of course the country was on
the ration for many items you know it's
we think things are tough now it was uh
553 probably
um
again you know I wouldn't be able to say
um I think that uh
I I don't have any answers to this
question to be honest but but it's it's
it's it's a good question we should look
at that absolutely Gabriel it's been
fascinating talking to you today thank
you so much thank you
uh just before I go bit of breaking news
to uh bring you we've had some data on
mortgage approvals during the last half
hour or so figures published from the
bank of England show that the number of
mortgage approvals being made to home
buyers bounced upwards in March the
bank's money and credit report said that
mortgage approvals for house purchases
Rose significantly to 52 000 in March
that was up from forty four thousand one
hundred in February however the bank of
England said that the latest total
remains below the monthly average for
2022 of 62 700 very interesting that
that is actually uh in keeping with what
we've heard from some of the big
mortgage lenders of late uh Nationwide
Building Society the second largest
player in the market saying only this
week of course that house prices Rose
last month the Halifax has been saying
they've been rising for much of this
year so uh interesting to see those
disparities sorting themselves out there
that's it from me today I'm back
tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock do hope
very much to see you then in the
meantime do stay tuned after this short
break Anna Jones is up with no doubt all
the latest reaction to that speech from
president zielinski in The Hague see you
tomorrow
foreign